now of your four steps I bet you did one
cool - cool three or you put something
together not you I'm not sure if this is
sufficient okay so let me walk you
through it Bluebird let's test it okay
now by the way you will have noticed
even though I didn't put it here on the
question that again this is one of the
ones you got to be careful where the
first level values not just zero or one
which are the ones that normally is
right because if you had a zero or one
sided polygon you'd be in some truffle
right so the first allowed value is N
equals two okay so I'm gonna go with the
right-hand side okay I'm just going to
solid in and I get three minus two times
180 which is your Navy which sure enough
is the angle sum of a three sided
polygon right track okay so fun
assumption
okay now these are the challenge starts
right because this assumption so far
it's just algebra right well when you
start to go to the next step you have to
move into geometry that's why I
mentioned that you need a diagram okay
so the question is how do you put
together a diagram when you don't know
because you're not a is you don't know
how many Sciences thing has or how many
angles it has they're really the same
thing okay now I think that question is
the same question is how do you how do
you express or articulate a series when
you don't know how many terms it has now
you already know the solution to that
we've been doing all the time right so
I'm going to use the same method for
geometry okay so that's my assumption
what do I have to prove I have to prove
that it's true for the k plus one case
so this K minus two just become K minus
month what's of 180 okay so my approach
would take this what we were required to
prove and Jordan okay so what does it
look like you have to lay down some
ground rules right so let the polygons
big now can you see I said it's a
polygon right so I'm assuming this some
polygon which fits these rules right so
I'm going to say let it be defined by a
certain set of points now a three-sided
polygon how many points and so at a
sided polygon will have K points right
now I want K plus 1 okay so I'm gonna
call the points because I kind of call
them ABCD because I don't know what the
last one will be right so I'm gonna call
them
point one and point two and point three
all the way up to now because I need to
go I'm required to prove kit that's why
I'm gonna get one more okay so I've got
point K and then point K plus-1 wherever
that is okay what does this thing look
like well I didn't know about any of
these aims are right but then again it
doesn't matter what anything was
individually are because I'm just
interested in one they add up to okay so
if I start with P 1 and P 2 okay and
then have another point B 3 now this
point if I gave you say a series right
like saying even though we go to 4 6 and
then you'd say dot dot dot just like I
did here right so I'm gonna go point 1
point 2 point 3 to point K I have to
write cuz what are you gonna put in
there you don't know how many what it's
gonna do okay it's just gonna do its
thing
okay this is a point k right now I don't
know what's in between here but I do
know what happens next because I'm
almost at the end of the shape right so
I've got point k plus 1 over here and
then by the end I whip background enough
to be okay so this is my polygon okay so
how would I here classy isn't it now how
would I argue from this and then keep in
mind how am I going to use my assumption
right how do I argue that this is the
case okay well I try to work in my
assumption right my assumption is about
the angle solve of a polygon with cave
sighs okay I have a polygon with K sides
in this diagram it's just not drawn in
properly right all you need is another
life we said a K sided polygon has K
points in it right so I should have K
points from here all the way up to yeah
right that's why it's
so if I join up this that's curved sorry
you got the nd okay
I've created a case I pulled on there
right so I can say the angle song off
now of course not talking about these
shapes and describing them right
how would you name this how do we name
polygons usually when I've got an actual
one right you like well this triangle
over here I might call a VC right okay
because we name it based on its points
right I know the points of this polygon
it just happens that I don't know how
many there are
okay so I'd say the angle sum of
polygons well that's a p1 and then is p2
and p3 whoa whoa l2p okay right that's
the polygon again I kind of Mabel
appoints today how many there are
the English some of that polygon is
given by the angles some off I'm just
going to say their sum is equal to now
he's my assumption right cuz I assumed
that such a shape should have that angle
son right okay minus 2 degrees by
assumption okay so I know what the angle
sum in that pot is and now how do I get
the in some of the whole shape the k
plus 1 pulling you up just have out of
what's left over which is I trying right
so I would say the angle sum off now
what's this shape right well again I
want to describe it on the basis of its
points right but unlike the previous one
actually
it is three the first one is p1 the
second one is PK and the last one is P
the end of some of this polygon is 180
degrees now I can logically I can either
say that because it's blatantly obvious
or if you want to go down without I
assume nothing round it's like well I
prove this case already
that was my test case okay so it's true
therefore the angle sum of the whole
shape right which is which has K plus 1
points and K plus side one side is that
previous shape there plus the 180 I was
just talking about okay so I'll just
break apart the factorization
no no no okay it stands to argue with
you want to go straight from here to
here I think it is pretty obvious right
but then again deductions being about
doing obvious things a little bit long
so it's still not that bad
when you think about the link that
compares about other ones like Fibonacci
that was terrible
I think the tricky spot is tweak your
right diagram and think about how you're
gonna use it okay so Jojo Chris are
really not that difficult it's just
you've got to get the right mindset for
it you're going to draw a diagram in the
right way I'd like